[Music]  you know the thing is I was gonna wear  this earlier and it just didn't look  like the Jiffy Pop  George Clooney gushing over wife Amal of  2018 Met Gala on Monday Amal is a  co-chair of this year's event and  stunned on the carpet in this pant with  over skirt look by Richard Quinn the  actor joked that the pair made it an  early night on Sunday in preparation for  the soiree I went out to dinner today  what do you think about the oceans movie  that you started the franchise being  around the Met Gala yeah that's funny I  think I gotta watch out they might rob  me tonight what do you think of the most  left I'm always proud of them  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]